[Music]
you need a doctor
i am a
i doctor have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease come here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of me
wants to hunt
and consume blood
and you control it
i don't know
half the city wants to kill you
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
other half wants to control you hey uh
dr mike you and i should stay in touch
not doing anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
michael
i've known you since you were a child
you have a gift
you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this can be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
even overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel
got tired of doing the whole good guy
thing huh what's up guy
morbius is a marvel character who's been
an important part of the universe
he's brilliant i'm pure
it's finally possible he's strong
he's got some unique powers
but his powers seem to be out of his
control
what's happening
i love the opportunity to do something
transformational i've become something
different
it was a very intense physical role
more viasat is most frail and then most
monstrous
this superhero super villain
putting a new marvel character on screen
that had never been on screen before
it'll be fun to see where we could go
without there's a web of opportunity
[Music]
you